ah
hope people are hearing me okay i was
having some trouble with this mic
earlier this week
but
you'll have to let me know
if you can hear me all right
ah
there we go i was waiting for reactions
i was starting to wonder
are people seeing me
um
and i wasn't sure
um but i guess now now we're getting a
reaction so good good
hope everyone is doing lovely
this is this is a little bit of a work
in progress so
be gentle please
um
i will be curious to see who the first
to call out in the chat as to
what i'm doing
here i'm hoping there's some who know
please
um but we'll see
there's no starbucks salted caramel this
year really
i know they cut that
that is a bummer
uh watching the stream while making
homemade chicken noodle soup ooh lovely
the title says spoopy season live stream
is that a typo it is not it is not a
typo i wrote it that way on purpose i'm
excusing myself from that very yes
carowind i know you know
i know you know
um
you're either mr thomas or something
from pan's labyrinth okay you're
you're in the right neighborhood but
this is something way more specific and
actually very specific to me so
ah
like i know it's referencing like one of
my least viewed side projects but still
still
there it is thank you black cover
there we go
um this this is me working on
uh wisp which is my fawn bard on quill
and sword the d and d um
uh live stream that i do every other
thursday
so if you've been missing that you've
been missing out on this character
branded my first time trying to embody
this character personally but
there you go
if i had to guess maybe maybe robin
goodfella aka puck okay now if you don't
know quill and sword that's not a
terrible guess
i would really love to play that part
shall we this idol pageant see
lord what fools these mortals be
huh
my mom knows how to make homemade
chicken noodle soup broth but i never
had uh and i never had to use
store-bought broth because it's too
salty good point we use turkey and
chicken bone carcasses and veggies ooh
that sounds lovely
on your twitch live stream i told you
that i'm going to be a reindeer for
halloween you told me that was a bold
choice how is it bold because you're
mixing holidays i don't think my stance
was that
um complicated
but at the very least like i'm not
surprised most people didn't guess wisp
but
um like i i'm very happy that lots of
people were correctly getting fawn vibes
so that that makes me happy that tells
me i was doing something right
um
i'm gonna be the the scariest thing of
all a capitalist
you you already are that by having to
exist in this society
scary every day
can't decide what to be from for
halloween mermaid pirate demon a demon
pirate mermaid why is that hard come on
uh
hey there molly i haven't said hello
hello carowind um pirates castillo ben
miss wicked wolf homebody emily black
cover i did kind of say hi to you
because you got it right cappuccino
uh lots of folks in nice to see you all
uh
dead dead towerdom
i don't know how to pronounce that one
uh so this is a reminder that super
chats is uh the unless you are on the
discord which is a patreon uh exclusive
perk
uh super tests are the only way to
guarantee i will read and respond to
your thing and that will also get you a
heart i do try and keep up with the chat
so i don't want you to think that i am i
am
pay walling off uh me actually answering
your thing but the only thing that
guarantees it is the super chat and that
also gives you my appreciation and a
heart so
uh there's that
oh thank you rowan
[Music]
where'd i get the fake here's etsy
same with the horns for that matter
i'm dressing as normal if people ask i'm
a homicidal maniac they look like
everyone else very nice wednesday very
nice
so cool doctor who is coming back on
halloween my usual
watch of nightmare before christmas will
have to be bumped i'm cautiously excited
for it i keep forgetting it's happening
on how that's really gonna make
halloween day itself really cramped for
me
um
you know because i'm actually going to
be going out and doing stuff with my kid
so
yeah
so the the the main reason i put all
this together is because this is pretty
much how it will be once i have the
complete thing from about the waist up
like maybe i'll finagle a little bit
more on the top because right now it's
kind of plain and bland i like i like
the blue but it's it's kind of dull but
um the thing that's really going to cap
this off is stuff that a i can't afford
right now and b i couldn't show off even
if i had it which is i want to get
hooves
and i want to get fur leggings
and i feel like that's going to round
the whole thing out
perfectly
if my schedule keeps up
as it has i may have to go to bed early
halloween oh
that'd be a shame
oh god i'm gonna have to
god i gotta get pumpkins
so much stuff to do leather traps top
maybe
leather chaps bottom
i was watching corpse bride but i
decided to watch this and said carbs
pride's decent
i remember feeling like almost the
inverse about corpse bride that i do
about
um
nightmare before christmas at least in
regards to the music because i feel like
corpse pride would be much better if you
stripped out the songs like they're not
bad but they it
it works better as a straight story
whereas i feel like nightmare before
christmas would work much better if the
entire thing was a musical and nobody
just spoke
um
but
uh i'm being a painter over this uh but
joel and then gmail is that address
correct i i've i messaged him earlier
today
to ask him to confirm his email
uh he hasn't got excuse me
he hasn't gotten back to me so it may be
my fault because i don't normally
communicate with him through email
um
but uh that seemed like the best way to
do it so i i am now i i'm waiting to
confirm that email address with him i
got your email we'll get this sorted
uh
vera tumnus wild
[Music]
corpse bride bite your tongue oh hi meg
how's it going good to see you here
why don't you bite my tongue for me
i'm not sure that's actually sexy i
don't know what that was
getting drunk tonight
no
no
one hard cider
does not get me drunk i am not that much
of a lightweight
did you hear the rumors that we're
getting an army of darkness reboot
uh to go along with evil dead rise army
of darkness reboot apparently aiming to
give us a reboot at ash williams i did
not and i also don't believe it
i have a hard time believing anybody
would be that stupid
i mean there's a reason the one time
they did remake evil dead they didn't
try and do ash williams again that would
have been very very stupid
so
i i did not hear the rumor and since
you're calling it a rumor i very firmly
do not believe that
if it happens i'll have an opinion but
like i don't have an opinion on rumors
i'm actually seeing a production of
arsenic and old lace on halloween
weekend interesting choice
not sure if this counts as a halloween
thing but i've been re-watching happy
tree friends
i used to have a happy tree friend's
shirt
oh god that
that takes me back
that and phone me the squirrel
uh i was into phone me more than i was
into happy like i liked happy tree
friends it was fine but like foamy was
where it was at for me
uh in the early 2000s
oh dear
oh i am old
they're making a hocus pocus too what
are your thoughts
i don't have any unlike most people in
my generation i don't really care about
hocus pocus
uh hocus pocus for me kind of falls into
a little bit of the same situation as um
uh
power rangers and i know that sounds
like an odd comparison but it insofar as
in both cases i was probably about
one or two years too old to get into it
so
like lots of people who are part of the
same generation as me but a year or two
younger love that stuff me i was like
this isn't very good because i was old
enough to have
a more refined critical perspective and
realize that it did
no it was it wasn't great
uh oh hi knit this and crochet tiger
good to see you
should i wear a harness to go with my
reindeer onesie um
depends on the style of harness i
suppose
i'll leave it at that
have you watched chucky i'm not really a
big slasher fan but enjoyed the first
two episodes i oh is that what what is
that even on i'm not sure i have
whatever service that's on so no i
haven't as yet oh
new type jb lee thank you so very much
you get a heart
uh i know you're not a fan of big two
comics but i recommend immortal hulk for
halloween it's a self-contained 50 issue
series that just wrapped up last week
i've heard very good and very
interesting things about immortal hulk
um
doesn't mean i'll get to it it kind of
falls under the category of somebody's
probably going to have to pay me to get
to this but
um i have heard of it and i've heard of
interesting things
uh hocus pocus is a movie i can never
criticize because it's so baked in my
nostalgia and that's fair i've got
movies like that too i was just a little
too old to really
be the target demographic for that like
i remember
thinking that like they shouldn't have
given bit midler buck teeth and that you
know the jokes were a little too dumb so
like that's what i mean when i say it
was like a one or two years too old for
that movie
um
i'm on candy duty this year then again
i've been on candy duty since i was 12
years old well why why break the streak
now chucky i think is on peacock
peacock's free i think free with ads
maybe i'll try it probably not i
probably won't i am
i am buried in work anyone a fan of over
the garden wall yes
ooh i should watch that this month
re-watch it over the garden wall is mwah
oh
oh it's so good
over the garden wall so good
oh
it's awesome and it's creepy and it's
weird and it's charming and
yes
yes to that
um
so i would report that i saw the new
halloween movie today as soon as they
introduced a gay couple that lived in
michael myers childhood home my heart
sank as i knew what was coming
oh of course
labyrinth is a big one for me when it
comes to nostalgia now see pirates have
a problem with that statement because
the way you word that
implies to me
that you think it doesn't hold up absent
nostalgia
and we're gonna have a fight if that's
the position you are taking
on labyrinth
no i know it's not perfect but i
personally have no there there's nothing
that is quote unquote wrong with it that
i care about or that i actually think is
a problem
would you ever cosplays michael or david
from lost boys probably not i don't want
to do the hair
uh if you say anything positive about
haunted muppets haunted mansion we are
going to rumble okay meg here's the
closest i will come to positive about it
because it is a
deeply cynical product it is basically
just
them it is just the muppets plugged into
the attraction
here is the thing though i just so
happen to be at the meeting point for
the venn diagram of people who really
like haunted mansion and who really like
the muppets and
as i fall in there
there were lots of little touches i
liked like i liked how many tiny details
from the ride showed up in the special
it doesn't work as a narrative of any
kind shape or form but as someone who
loves that attraction and grew up
listening to the record
that has friggin um ron howard playing a
teenager on it
as someone who grew up on that there
were enough like little things little
licks of music like and specific ghosts
and certain things that i'm like oh yeah
cool and it being muppets i was coming
oh okay and there was also one good joke
there was one legit good joke
and that is when the various dead
husbands of the bride
all of whom she's killed
um
are
talking about their um
their time with her in their
relationship with her before she killed
them and then it gets to the penguin and
the penguin just goes
and they'll go oh god why would you say
that what is wrong with you ah i'm sorry
i laughed that was a good joke
um so that's the one highly qualified
and the one unqualified bit of praise
i'm going to give that um because
yeah it's it's not
it's not good
i'm not even sure what it is it's not
even special it's like it's like 40
minutes it's very strange
like in a bad way
oh captain omni thank you very very much
for the super chat do you think evil
dead rise is going to be able to shape
the curse of not having bruce's ash
making it not as good i mean
i haven't been tracking what's going on
with evil dead right so i'm not even
entirely sure i know
exactly what it is or what it's planned
to be
um
i mean the main thing is i think
i think they already
proved that
you can have a remake of evil dead
minus ash that's probably the best way
to do it
and if you're going to do it you should
probably do it straight because
most of the humorous ass humor-ish
aspects of it are somehow funneled
through ash either his reaction to them
or he's providing them directly there
are some other things that are kind of
ridiculous and funny about it even if
you didn't have ash but i don't think
having anyone else's reaction other than
ashes to those things is going to land
the same way
but that's me maybe they'll figure it
out
maybe not probably not i doubt they will
i'm trying to get this youtubers
attention but i think her spambot is
censoring my comments any advice i have
no advice whatsoever i don't use bots
because i am not tech savvy enough
probably should um
i mean if you're getting caught up with
a spam bot that means you're either
saying the exact same thing over and
over and over again or you are um
sending messages way too rapid fire to
back to back
so
i i don't know which is the case and i
have no advice to give
i hate the song dancing in the moonlight
okay well you're allowed to be wrong
have you seen bad taste i no
i never got around to that one i have
seen
meet the feebles and i've seen brain
dead
or dead alive if your country's stupid
that would be my country i just took a
dig out by the way i'm allowed um but no
i never did get around to bad taste when
it comes to early peter jackson i've
been re-listening to creepypastas some
of the scary some of the some for laughs
jeff the killer i never got into
creepypastas
so
like i know what they are i know that
they're like a thing but
just it's not it just is not something i
ever really explored
what are your thoughts on the pet
cemetery
bit the the original and the remake i've
only seen most of the original didn't
see the remake
laughed my way through quite a bit of
the original
cuz
[Music]
i know it's it's horrible and morbid but
um
uh
the the kid's shoe just flying through
the air after he gets hit by the truck
i'm sorry i laughed my ass off at that
am i a terrible person
yes but not because of that
bookworm of the fandoms hello there my
friend you get a heart thank you so much
for the super chat
i second the immortal hulk is amazing i
love bruce banner immortal hulk was a
fun read for me i only read the first 20
issues so far which is the creepiest
doctor who episode in your opinion
um
i know a lot of people when it comes to
creepy doctor who episodes tend to
either say
blink which is very creepy but for me um
sort of that's mostly on the initial
watch
once you know what's going on it
the atmosphere isn't quite as tense
and then a lot of people will
cite um
waters of mars
which i think is overrated almost across
the board not bad but overrated in
almost every area including being scary
i don't find that one scary
at all
um
so for me
it's the empty child and the doctor
dances
um because the concept of the empty
child itself both the way
um it's depicted
just this this gas mask wearing child
that doesn't seem to understand what's
going on
and
that's one of the few cases where
finding out what it is actually makes it
scarier to me
um and it's the way the the doctor has
has his line
there isn't a child
in the world there isn't a child alive
who wouldn't tear the world apart
to save his mummy and this child can
there's something to me especially now
as a parent um
deeply terrifying about that kind of
power in the hands of a child that is
not even evil but just
doesn't
know better
just does not have the maturity and the
moral and the development of a moral
compass to understand the damage that
it's doing that to me is terrifying
so i and i think the atmosphere still
holds up really good even if you know
what's going on and know that it turns
out all right
uh horror fang rock is a great haunted
house story i still haven't seen that
one
uh oh new type jb lee once more thank
you thank you so much
um what are your thoughts on the gothic
horror era of doctor who that was headed
by hinchcliffe and holmes over praised
rightly praised it's a beloved period
i've only seen a couple things from that
period i've enjoyed what i've seen
uh so far
so it seems rightly praised i mean if
you want to say that's not your
aesthetic and it's not your jam that's
fine but it is well done
excuse me
um do you reckon the other reason you
find waters of mars overrated is that
you're not as invested in tenant as a
character as some others
i
don't
think
so
i mean the thing is i never really
went in that hard on the
um
on the whole time lord triumphant thing
or sorry time lord victorious thing
because
i mean up until they started releasing
new stuff years and years and years and
years later none of which i've seen or
read as yet
it is a
thing that gets set up and then more or
less resolves
within the same 20 minute period
so
it's hard for me to get any investment
or even catharsis out of that
um
so no i don't i don't think it's that
i'm uninvested in his character i just
i think all the things that are in it
even the things that work don't work as
well at least not for me don't work as
well as a lot of people claim they do
who's your favorite uh doctor who come
in from new who donna noble
donna noble has left the library
donna nobu has been saved
uh have you seen the cowboy bebop
trailer did you watch any of the anime
so if by trailer you mean the new video
that just came well yes i saw the
trailer there was a newer video that
just came out that was much cooler than
the trailer was
i still hate that vicious is in it
because yes i've seen the anime and the
anime is good but very overrated
um i did a whole video on it you can
actually find that um but vicious is
easily the worst thing about the entire
show and i hate that he's in this
he is he is a
boring generic stupid monotonous
pretentious lousy character
and i really wish he wasn't in it
i have to give credit to the new
candyman film as the brother of the main
female character characters in a
relationship with a man and neither of
them end up dead or face danger that's a
nice change of pace at least
uh any opinion on halloween three season
of the witch some people hate it and i
think it's great i
have yet to see
a halloween film all the way through
any of them
i've never seen a single one
captain omni once more thank you so very
much you get a heart frankenstein and
werewolves are my favorite monsters but
i find vampires to be less interesting
unless it's dracula or a singular
vampire where do you stand
um
could it be oversaturation for me well i
mean vampires were definitely
oversaturated for a while
personally
the thing is i gravitate towards
vampires but here's why
i feel like you can there's a lot more
freedom with vampires and they appeal to
me more as a storyteller because i think
there's a lot more that you can do with
vampires
whereas with frankenstein and werewolves
they're good but there's
unless you are gonna completely change
the fundamentals of what those monsters
are
there is a very small number of stories
that you can tell
with those monsters at least ones that i
think work
whereas vampires whatever you may think
of the various iterations
you know
using vampires as a horde creature as a
singular threat as um you know something
in a romance setting in a you know and
and i think i feel like there's a lot
more flexibility in how you can utilize
a vampire whereas werewolves
you're pretty much always telling a
curse story and in frankenstein it's
always a
science
goes too far story i mean it has to be
that's what they are built to be whereas
vampires are more of a gen they play on
more generalized fears which gives you
more freedom of what to do with them
are or were we oversaturated with
zombies it seems to have eased off a
little um but yeah we have been for a
bit
have you seen nightmare before christmas
then oh of course i've seen that one
saw that in the theater when it first
came out
coming to the end of my first week fully
out as transit school oh that's great
louise feeling amazing to be wearing
clothes that i feel good in and hear my
correct name be used by teachers oh
that's wonderful
have you ever seen dancing with the
stars nope
are you excited for series 13 of doctor
who or do you just want the chimney
error to be
over i want series 13 to be good but i
don't have a lot of confidence that it
will be so i am approaching series 13
with
just a general sense of tension
do you plan to see dune oh yes i will
indeed be seeing doom
are you why are you upset they're
remaking an american werewolf in london
you think that the original is overrated
i do but it's also a product of its time
and the things that make it good
you can't recapture
it was a
monument of
of a transformation sequence but you'll
never it'll never be the first time for
that kind of transformation again
so
you know trying to recapture that and
they've tried now several times to
recapture the slightly
funny vibe while still being a horror
movie and falling on their face and if
all you're capturing is the vibe just
make a new damn movie
what are your thoughts on edgar allan
poe
um uh the
the main thing that i think about edgar
allan poe these days is um oh hang on
am i still up
on my end it went down are you folks
still seeing me
let me know
okay
all right so it's just my playback
that's being stupid all right that's
fine then um
the the thing that's funny to me to
think about edgar allan poe was i had
forgotten and then somebody on tick tock
reminded me that um
he's from boston
and so now i tend to think about
um
edgar allen poe and the you know his
macabre works
with a boston accent
uh a midnight dank and dreary as i
pondered weak and weary became a
wrapping on my parlor door
uh have you seen no time to die yet it
kept my it kept my dad awake so five
stars for me i have not i don't know
when i'm gonna get to see it
um it's hard for me to prioritize um
these things especially now that like
the pretty much all the reviews other
than doctor who go to the break room now
so i don't feel as pressured to get to
things right away
uh is is it me or
or is the treehouse of horror episodes
just no i don't know i haven't seen one
in probably a decade
oh
captain omni once more thank you so very
much i do appreciate it a lot have you
ever read any vampirella and if not i
recommend christopher priest's current
run she's one of the few vampires i'm
really into
uh i have not
i have however seen someone cosplay
vampirella
very accurately and that was at
terrificon
whoo
i'm shocked they let her on the floor
with that outfit
uh
weird timing but i just finished up the
stranded uh audio set the character of
tanya bell is a fantastic example of
trans representation played by trans
actress too that's great glad to hear
that
uh
off topic rachel levine open transgender
official has been sworn in as an admiral
of the u.s public health commission
corps yes i heard about that today
yeah that that was that was very nice
that was very welcome news
um oh meg
meg
who just gave me 6.66
cheeky
do you have a favorite sfx makeup from a
movie like legit makeup no cgi
oh
that that is
tough um
like i tend to lean towards a lot of the
stuff that um doug jones has performed
and obviously he didn't
create the makeups that he's in but
you know whether it be
um
whether it be
uh the shape of water or whether it be
um the fawn from
pan's labyrinth he's he he gets put in
really really good makeup
um
there's probably some others
honestly i'm still just kind of
impressed that hellboy got done
completely practically and moved as well
as it did on ron pearlman the
david
harbor one i didn't watch it but i did
see clips of him and like god he looks
like he can't move at all
um
there's probably other oh
yes rainy shed tim
tim curry in legend okay yes yes no that
takes it that's that is the one yes
thank you i i was actually at the time i
read your comment i was literally just
thinking i'm gonna think of something
once this is done that i should have
said and that is the thing that i would
have thought of later so thank you for
saying yes
yes darkness in legend
holy
[ __ ]
so good rose mcgowan
thank you very much no questions or
comments but you get a heart all the
same thank you thank you so much
got to introduce over the garden wall to
some friends recently they're gonna have
potatoes and molasses stuck in their
head for life
oh
that's so good
yeah i definitely should have re-watched
that
do you think doctor who will get a new
year's special
i have no idea it's odd to me that
sometimes like
somebody asked me if i thought that
a russell t davis would um bring back
the christmas special versus new years
and my thought is i don't think the
showrunner has control over that by
themselves pretty sure bbc planners have
more control over that
so
yeah i don't know
i don't know again i have no way of
gauging that between reading scp
documents would recommend for halloween
good ones included the flesh that hates
old fairgrounds anything related to
s
sarkicism
don't know what that is
doug jones would be a great scarecrow
you know the tall and extremely lanky
and thin scarecrow i honestly feel like
um
billy from
[Music]
hocus pocus is a borderline scarecrow in
terms of the way he performs it
what's your favorite trash tv i don't
know
gotham probably
gotham is trash but god it's fun trash
uh it was lovely to hear tim curry as
auntie whispers uh but it did make me
feel a bit sad
yeah i i am glad that he he has started
working again since since his stroke but
yeah it it is tough that that said it's
actually become easier for me to listen
to since i met him in person
um
because
even with the restrictions on his voice
he's so much humanity just comes through
um and being able to you know for all of
20 seconds but being able to meet him in
person
um
[Music]
i i've i'm now less troubled by
when i hear him speak now
um something about
experiencing it in person made it much
more like oh
oh that's okay
that's still him
um let's see oh new type jb lee
thank you again
thoughts on lovecraft does he get too
much credit um
yes and no
so
here's the one to punch on that the guy
honestly deserves a lot of credit for
pioneering cosmic horror
he he just
he was doing something that almost no
one else was doing and doing it better
for a very very long time
that said
i kind of wish not so many people used
the term lovecraft or lovecraftian for
the genre or the type of horror i wish
they would just say cosmic horror
i kind of want to detach his name from
it just because the guy was
so racist like
yes i know even at the time
the world you know
people white people in america in
general were pretty damn right i mean
we're a lot of us are pretty racist now
but like we're pretty damn racist at the
time and openly so but even for the time
he was real racist
so i i kind of wish fewer people would
directly evoke his name
i definitely wish fewer people would
like make him a character
in things like don't
don't do that
do you read poetry and if so do you have
any favorites um i don't read books of
poetry um i read poetry like in scant
bits here and there i have some friends
who are poets who i'm always very
flattered when they share their work
with me but um like books of poetry or
whatnot isn't something that i generally
seek out
um i didn't know you met tim curry when
did that happen that happened at boston
fan expo
2017
i think
pretty sure
it's 2017 or 2016. i can't remember now
it was one of the two i wasn't actually
going to go at all until i found out
that he was going to be there i'm like i
have to go and i i did almost nothing
other than drive down meet him and drive
back like i walked the floor a little
bit
but normally for a con i'll get a i'll
get a hotel room and stay the night and
do two days i i didn't i didn't have the
time i didn't have the money but um
but
yeah no he that was
that was really something
hmm
thinking on the web show asked lovecraft
i don't know i didn't know it existed
my immediate hope is that
uh his answer to every single question
regardless of what it is and regardless
of context is just some version of
um
it's because of the non-white people
like with really wide eyes
that's that's what i want it to be don't
know if it is
um
but
uh if you had a mini scope
what would you want to put in it
i'm not sure if i totally know what that
is
um i'm missing the context on that if
you tell me what it is i'll probably be
like oh yeah yeah yeah but
are you gonna see the new batman movie
starring robert pattinson yeah
eventually
i'm not super excited about it because
the trailer was very
action focused and
the pitch i remember being much more
this is the this is batman the detective
and
i don't want
this to be batman the detective insofar
as he just beats up suspects and get the
answers like i want to legitimately have
to solve crap and there's none of that
in the trailer it may still be in the
movie but it's not in the marketing
right now rose mcgowan again thank you
so much
rumors of sony buying doctor who your
thoughts
they they're not they can't okay so that
that was a whole
that was a whole confusion
over that sony
is not
will not isn't trying to is not in a
position to
buy doctor who what sony did was sony
acquired bad wolf studio which is
currently producing doctor who but bad
wolf studio doesn't own doctor who
the ip is owned by the bbc
this the
bad wolf production is simply the
production that is currently going to be
working on it but they don't own it
so
sony acquiring them never ever put them
in line to actually acquire doctor who
in much the same reason that when
microsoft bought rare they didn't
suddenly have
the rights to donkey kong because
nintendo owned that they just had rare
making the games for them so that the
the fact that that was ever a thing that
was being talked about was just massive
misunderstanding of how production and
acquisition and ip rights work
um have you ever taken a nap during the
daytime oh yeah of course i have
uh
the first trailer for the batman was
detective focused
it really wasn't the first trailer i
mean it was trying to evoke seven
i wouldn't call that a detective focus
though
uh favorite story of season 23 time of
the ronnie paradise tower is dealt with
abandonment or dragon fire
um at time of speaking the only one of
those i've seen is time of the ronnie so
i'm just gonna putt that question
for right now if it's all the same
um
from carnival of monsters oh i haven't
seen that one yet
okay that's why i didn't get it
do you like shakespeare plays i like
some of them
i think shakespeare
shakespeare was very good at what he did
i don't always love what he did
some of what he did has held up better
than others but he was real good at his
job
captain omni my goodness
all kinds of love coming from you today
i love it
something badass for a non-binary rep a
badass non-binary barbarian i'm a huge
conan fan redsonian he-man fan so i want
raw warrior goodness oh
yeah
yeah we yes i i would be so in favor of
that
uh have you seen just beyond on disney
plus nope haven't heard of it don't know
what it is
favorite chapter of over the garden wall
see that's the problem it's been so long
since i've seen it they're bleeding
together in my head
i'm leaning towards um
either the haunted house one or the um
or the farming village
uh but
it's it's been a little while favorite
tim burton movie
like here's the thing i will argue that
his best movie is sweeney todd i go back
and forth as to whether it's my favorite
i think between that and betelgeuse
what if shakespeare doesn't hold up um i
mean some of it it has to do with the
story's just been ape too many times
um you know by other people who've
redone it recycled um his stuff although
to be fair a lot of his plots were
recycled as well
um
but there's things like taming of the
shrew which is great up until the ending
which is terrible um so you know there's
things like that
would you ever see six if it does a
national tour i would like to would i
ever as a practical matter probably not
i doubt it would come to vermont
which classic whose story is up next for
review if i'm at if i may ask
dragon fire is the next one up and i
really want to get it in for this month
um oh
okay meg thank you so much for stopping
in
much love
i appreciate it and thank you for the
super chat earlier as well
um
i miss my twitch emotes
i gotta get some more of those made
uh how are we for time
okay i had to do math in my head because
normally i started seven this time i
started at 7 30.
would you ever do a burlesque number
uh song to anaconda by nicki minaj nope
nope absolutely not oh discord thank you
carowind thank you very very much
pull that up
let's see what we've got and a reminder
that the other way of super chats is to
guarantee that i answer questions is
that there is a live stream channel on
the discord server which is a perk for
the patreon supporters so patreon.com
council of geeks maybe check that out
hey why not anyways
first up
um
so what if the flux
it's dr emmett brown's flex capacitor
and the doctor is on an epic quest to
stop biff tan and aka yuno who
unleashing the evils of the universe and
she doesn't
know because
no one
did 2 20 20. um
like there's zero possibility of that
being the case but that's a fun idea i
kind of want someone to do like a
webcomic version of that idea
um i'm just in here to say hey i'm here
because it's either this or watching my
dad watch the braves and i hate the
braves
fair i don't watch sports of any kind so
uh i get you oh
brian all right i'm back so i'm seeing
the chat and brian l you get a heart got
your book can't wait to read it thank
you oh that's wonderful
i hope
i hope that you like it
and i hope if you like it maybe you'll
think about reviewing it on goodreads
what who said that answer
[Music]
uh why don't you like slasher movies
there's two formulaic
by and large like the
there are occasional exceptions but for
the most part the characters are so
shallow and the story is so
repeated it's the same thing every time
most people that i know who really like
slashers are really into the kills like
they're gorehounds or they're really
into makeup effects and while i can
appreciate those things they're not
enough to carry a movie for me so
like i'm not gonna say there's no such
thing as a good slasher movie there are
a few but it's just not my genre
i liked ghost light i need to re-watch
ghost light because i remember
almost liking ghost light
um
ever seen anything from jimmy screamer
claus
it's not for everyone and much of what
he does is a fever dream
where the dead go to die still haunts me
none of those words rang a pal at all
so uh no no i have not
would you ever cosplay as freddie
krueger or jason no because that's like
that's some of the most basic obvious
stuff ever like the only
the i would never cosplay as jason
because i don't have the build for it
the only way you could get me to cosplay
is freddy krueger is if i could get a
professional makeup artist to recreate
the actual makeup as opposed to have to
put a freaking rubber freddy face mask
on because i'm not doing that crap
vera if my channel takes off i will do a
five hour video essay on why your book
doesn't have enough nodding in it
you know what ben
i i expect from you a report on exactly
how many nods are in that book
because i could pull up the manuscript
and do uh and do a search
for the word not and find out for myself
but i'd rather have you
do some investigation and tell me how
many times
there's a nod
i'm into very specific slashers not the
genre in general do you like the movie
final girls never seen it
what about michael myers again like it's
it's such an obvious
costume and again like
i don't have the build for it
another author who helped develop cosmic
horror just as much uh
as hippopotamus love clan is franz kafka
aka
frank the jackdaw oh kofka
it's interesting because kafka
definitely did deal in a similar kind of
existential dread
um
that
lovecraft did
um
he sort of came at it from a different
angle
but they did kind of truck in similar
emotional cores
in some ways yeah
yeah
valid
i like it
speaking of ghost light the policeman
getting turned into primordial soup was
terrific if only for the cream of
scotland yard line i don't remember that
line at all
i really need to rewatch that one
excuse me
why do you like the song dancing in the
moonlight
because it's catchy and fun
dancing in the moonlight everybody
ah
friends kafka is my favorite last words
ever kill me or else you are a murderer
uh would you describe the setting of
1984 as kafka-esque
um
i guess you
could
the thing is it's orwellian that became
its own term
like okay so
orwell again kind of um
dealt with with a certain kind of
existential
fear but i think there's there's a
gradation
um
lovecraft funneled his existential views
just into flat out monsters
kafka got a bit more political with it
but could still get weird with stuff
like metamorphosis and then orwell was
just all politics version of existential
dread
excuse me
have you had any cuff gas experiences
not legitimate ones
no
as a um as a privileged upper middle
class white person
no i definitely haven't
are you familiar with the xena episode
where ted raymie sings dancing in the
mood light nope i didn't watch that much
of zena so no i didn't know that one
sorry vera i did you just asked me to
count something did you just give me
maths homework
yes
now the question is
are you going to do it
or are you going to disappoint me
trust me you don't want to know anything
about where the dead go to die i only
knew of it because of anna matt's review
and the little i saw him made me want to
poke my eyes out oh lovely
if i can give my thoughts on john kent
being bi oh of course you can logan
um keep in mind i mean zero offense but
i don't care as long as it's written
well and not ham-fisted
again
no offense intended
so
okay here's what i'm going to say
about that
in terms of the general sentiment logan
absolutely nothing wrong with that
there
is and this and i am not judging you
like i get it but here's what i'm going
to say you do have to be careful
about
vocalizing that sentiment
not that i'm saying you don't have the
right to say that you absolutely do but
the problem is when something like that
happens
to say
i don't care
or any variant thereof and i know that's
not the complete thought the complete
thought was
i don't care as long as it's well
written and i get that but the instant
you inject the words i don't care it
does appear to undermine and
um
neglect
the va the inherent value of the
representation even if it isn't good
so
you you want to be careful about putting
and i don't care sentiment or any
variant thereof out into the world
around something like this where
a lot of people
need
the representation
um again i'm not saying you can't feel
that way it's a totally valid way to
feel i'm not even saying you can't say
it i'm just saying be careful how
and when you express that that you're
not
diminishing or invalidating
um what people are taking away from the
uh the representation and the inclusion
cool
cool
uh are you wearing a wig nope
what do you think of lower decks are you
even a trekkie i i hesitate to call
myself a trekkie just because i don't
my my relationship with star trek is
spotty i do like star trek
i've only seen the first episode of
lower decks and it was fine
um i don't i'm i don't have paramount
plus so
you know don't
really i'm not gonna get it just for
star trek that i i suppose that's the
line i'm not enough of a trekkie to
shout out for the paramount plus service
so take that as you will
the 1954 animated film of animal farm is
pretty good even though they changed the
ending i never read that book
nor nor have i seen any of the
adaptations
that's one of those
um school reading staples that i never
got assigned
i went to the van gogh
exhibit in new york city last month i
tried to explain to them that he visited
his own exhibit in the future but they
didn't believe me
well brian not not everyone's gonna get
it
unfortunately
would you want paramount plus if they
gave you a free subscription
i mean what i wanted
eh would i take it sure
whatever
[Music]
[Laughter]
what's your favorite song of all time i
don't have one my feelings on songs
change too
frequently i do not have a favorite song
of all time
how's the cider it's good it's woodchuck
so of course it's good it's always good
made in vermont
that's the stuff
something i found out recently cartmel
had nothing to do with the master plan
it was never going to happen and i had
the show not ended
huh
do you have a source on that shoot me in
an email because
i'd love to dig into that because if
true i'd like to have that in my back
pocket as a piece of knowledge but i
kind of want to source that
i assume mel brooks's history of the
world part two series won't convince you
to get hulu either i'm sorry the what
the what now
no it wouldn't but
i'm curious all of a sudden
keep heart with your armpit i can't not
not with this because it's this is too
tight and i can't get in there but yes i
am capable
this this whole ah yeah this this outfit
is
snug on me it actually flattens my chest
a little bit
um
is luca halloween themed considering it
has sea monsters in it that's a stretch
a junker how drunk are you right now i
am not i am
mildly tipsy it was one cider i'm not
that much of a lightweight
thanks for understanding vera i'm always
afraid to post my thoughts on the
subject of that nature i'll try to say
it better again thanks for understanding
of course logan of course and like i
you've been around my channel you've
been in my chats long enough i know you
mean well
and so that's like that's why i want to
be as helpful as possible and and thank
you for understanding where i was coming
from when i answered the question there
we go everybody's good
uh return to oz is somewhat halloween
themed i mean it takes place in october
does it
okay
ah
let's see here
i think
might be wrapping it up soon so people
want to get
uh their questions and or super chats
give me money um in
this would be a good time to do it
because i am gonna wrap it up in a
little bit
uh it's a shame you're not drunk because
i would love for you to get the hiccups
right now i don't have to be drunk to
get the hiccups i actually get hiccups
freaking randomly and they're actually
really loud and really persistent and
they hurt
when i get them
so
favorite halloween treats snacks or
pastries
favorite unhealthy pumpkin [ __ ]
you know what he liked
i remember there were halloween theme i
don't see them anymore i remember they
were halloween-themed cadbury's eggs
where the the sort of goo inside was
green
i think the food coloring gave it a
slightly different consistency i liked
those
those were good
why do you always say that i'm wrong
because it's fun
you don't want me to
have fun
what's one show you are a fan of that
you feel doesn't get enough recognition
i'm intrigued uh about watching new
stuff at the moment
um
gargoyles
i feel like um
[Music]
when it comes to
[Music]
serialized storytelling in
and and more mature storytelling in
cartoons everyone cites avatar the last
airbender
and people my age will cite batman the
animated series
not enough people give gargoyles the
freaking credit it deserves for both
being as mature as batman if not more at
times and being way more serialized than
really any other cartoon up to that
point and for a long time after
gargoyles was great
not enough people give that credit
are you trying to get back at me for
trolling and harassing you
i don't know
you assume i have a plan to what i'm
doing
that's your first mistake
one more thing love i want to say uh
tiefling sorry for the misspelling and
remember don't waste your time bearing
grudges uh and live life with love in
your heart ah
thank you so much
uh
cadbury was decent up until nestle
gobbled them oh crap nestle bought them
well i will never buy a cadsberry
product again
[ __ ]
nestle is
like
people know my thoughts on
capitalism in general huge corporations
in particular nestle is one of the
absolute worst companies in the goddamn
world
do not buy a nestle product do not buy
anything from their subsidiaries ever
ever
ever
and if people want to check out
gargoyles by the way it's on disney plus
so if you've got that it's right there
the whole thing uh you only really
bother with the first two seasons i
don't know if they have uh the third
season the chronicles of goliath on it
don't bother with that the creator
disowned it said it was non-canon
but the first two seasons
oh man
we'll try to find more sources but i do
know that first mention uh
of the other was in a novel not written
by cartmel and the planned final stories
for sylvester mccoy didn't mention it
okay well i mean that's a start
um
because because they're so based off
that you did kind of make a leap because
there is a difference between
there's
there isn't a ton of direct evidence of
it in the work and this was never going
to happen
um because the way you said it before
implied that he at some point went on
the record and said yeah no i wasn't
going to do that and
that's not quite what you're selling me
now
uh if there's ever a live-action
gargoyles movie no but okay let's move
on hire whoever you want to do the
motion capture but have keith david back
in the as the voice of goliath well duh
duh
keith
oh keith david's voice
you know
a lot of people cite
um you know the disney robin hood now
zootopia or lion king as like being the
birthplace of a lot of furries
keith david as goliath
birthplace of a lot of monster [ __ ]
i guarantee it
do you like pillsbury yeah never
it's no not particularly
thank you so much for the super chat
it's me harry i also want to say thanks
for all the great content well thank you
thanks so much
just hopped on i love the horns i'm glad
you got to catch them uh zarita i
actually
am going to get going so you you just
caught them
excuse me
uh if you want a game to review i
recommend no more heroes by grasshopper
manufacturer i like it's
it's really best not to
um
recommend
fully 3d
free movement games for me either in
first person or third person i get
motion sick playing them i really i need
2d fixed camera or i need isometric
it's kind of where i'm at
um with that voice who can blame them i
know right carolyn
i'm not saying like that at that i'm
not saying i'm also not saying no
i'm back i'm back i'm back
um have you ever been to a corn maze
before yes once i will never do it again
um
i'm watching this on my tv across the
room and my cat looked up at you like
who is that
oh that's cute i love it i see i'm
trying to i should go but i can't keep
seeing fun stuff in the chat uh well
there's also the fact that carmel said
he wanted to bring mystery back to the
doctor and the master plan is the
opposite of that
uh
platt and aranovich take more credit for
it i mean yeah but also people are
saying the same thing about timeless
child and i would argue the exact same
thing in that case too but people still
make the argument so there seems to be a
a bit of a
disconnect for what people think counts
as mystery
there's quite a few star trek next
generation cast members in gargoyles oh
yeah oh yeah and um
frakes as david zanatos one of the best
cartoon villains ever he's great marina
certaina is awesome michael dorn comes
in the voice of character at one point
oh
it's good good stuff
um do you like pumpkin spice lattes
i'm over them i did for a time
what about undertale or delta
will play them at some point have not
yet
do you like pit bulls yeah they're cute
thank you for your review of doctor who
edge of reality i can use the 25 bucks
for something else yes please do oh dear
god
my favorite mythological monster
or storybook monster is the headless
horseman of sleepy hollow that's a good
pick
i'm one of one of my halloween staples
is the disney version of
of the legend of sleepy hollow
there's just there's that one
shot
where the horseman rears back he's got
the pumpkin and the sword he's just
laughing and it's it's
the horseman and the horse are like
almost completely black and it's like
this pinkish red light behind them and
the horns come in on the soundtrack ah
it's so good
oh
do you have a discord i do tara um
however it is a patreon perk so uh at
the two dollar tier or higher on my
patreon that gets you access to the
discord
uh would you play video game morality
play don't know enough about it to know
whether or not i would play it
um
sleepy hollow is not brainless it's
headless
[Music]
when the spooks have a midnight jamboree
can't keep singing um
so let me see here yeah i should yes i
should wrap it up i keep talking i i
should i
should wrap it up
um
oh yes thank you thank you carowind
she she she knows how to keep me in line
so uh tomorrow 10 30 a.m
twitch stream
still playing hades twitch.com
i'm sorry twitch.tv slash council of
geeks
join me there it's a lot of fun it's a
great game it's kind of horny i'm so
here for it i'm having a lot of fun uh
with the people who are joining me um on
that stream so
that is gonna
gonna wrap it up i hope everybody has a
great rest of the week a great rest of
the month i'm not gonna get to see you
again before halloween
so um
just take care
be well
be safe
be kind
because you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
mccabe